33 світові рекорди. Зокрема найбільший безпосадочний переліт без дозаправки у 1987 році.
20тисяч кілометрів за 25 годин 30 хвилин.
Найбільший серійний вантажний літак у світі-український "Руслан"
і досі залишається поза конкуренцією.
Ми його називаємо "Русланчиком"! Для нас він"Русланчик".
А ще його називають "красунчиком".
Бо планер літака, розроблений конструкторським бюро Антонова майже 40 років тому, досі вражає.
Завишки 21 метр- трохи нижче дев’ятиповерхівки.
Завдовжки майже 70 метрів, як середнє футбольне поле.
Максим Саноцький,заступник директора "Авіаліній Антонова",
більше 10 років працював у небі - інженером на борту, зокрема і"Руслана".
Його персональний рекорд- одного разу він не виходив з літака дев’ять діб.
Це задня кабіна екіпажу. Вона не з’єднана з кабіною пілотів.
Техніки з льотчиками спілкуються лише по внутрішньому зв’язку.
Так виглядає їх побут.
Максим Саноцький запевняє, що ці ліжка досі зручніші за полиці в найкращому СВ-вагоні потягу.
Крім однієї людини, яка має працювати під час польоту, усі інші можуть відпочивати.
Проте спати спокійно під час польоту важко.
Інженери в режимі онлайн мають стежити за роботою всіх систем літака.
І мають, у разі виникнення нештатної ситуації, спуститися у вантажний відсік.
І це нічим не відрізняється від робіт на бортукосмічного апарату.
Якщо,не дай Боже,не прибралася передня стійка або задня, або головна опора шасі.
Для цього є можливість розгерметизувати ці кабіни.
Є спеціальні оглядові лючки і можна зрозуміти,чи прибралося шасі чи ні.
Можливо, що просто замерз якийсь датчик.
Тобто шасі прибралося, а сигналізація не спрацювала.
В технічному ангарі"Руслан"побачити можна рідко.
Цей літак кілька років тому був модернізований іможе підняти у небо вантаж вагою 150 тонн.
Базова модель передбачає 100-120 тонн вантажу.
Кількість замовлень на такі вантажі з року в рік лише зростає, кажуть на підприємстві "Антонов".
Легендарна українська авіатрійка найвідоміших у світі літаків-
"красень Руслан",
"красуня Мрія"і ще один турбогвинтовИй літак"Антей"-
активно працюють, зокрема, за натівськими контрактами.
Державне підприємство"Антонов" - партнер програмиSALIS,
яка була створена для того, щоб 10 союзників по НАТО, серед яких Німеччина, Франція та Польща,
могли швидко розмістити свої сили та обладнання там, де вони потрібні.
І за офіційної інформацією, наданою на запитDW, .
країни-учасниці SALIS повністю задоволені рівнем наданих послугкомпанією "Антонов"
В межах контракту, підписаного в грудні 2018 року,
"Антонов"має забезпечити гарантований доступ до 5-ти зі своїх семи"Русланів"до кінця 2021 року.
Минулого року за договором SALIS було передбачено 1900 льотних годин.
Що саме та куди перевозили українці і чи продовжать співпрацюдалі - в НАТО не кажуть.
Лише вказують на те, що вSALISнаразі оцінюють свої вимоги на наступний період
Зазвичай контракти з НАТО підписуються на три роки.
І,за інформацією державного підприємства, тут вже давно і тісно співпрацюють з Альянсом.
В першу чергу, для літаків 124-х,які ще з середини2000-х років
виконують за програмою SALIS перевезення в інтересах НАТО.
Тепер вже закріплено в Конституції України курс на НАТО,
то наприкладі"Антонова"співпраця України з НАТО відбувалася вже десятиліття і більше тому.
Ще 10 років тому "Руслан" приблизно на 80%
залежав від російських виробників запчастин та комплектуючих.
І стикався з необхідністю модернізації та вдосконалення обладнання літака,
аби відповідати міжнародним вимогам авіаперевезень.
Робити це ставало дедалі складніше.
Російські виробники то ставили захмарні ціни, то затягували виконання робіт.
До того ж, "Антонов"з 2006 року мав договір з російською компанією"Волга-Дніпро".
Росіяни мали свої"Руслани", і , як зазначають опитані DW експерти,
не дуже були зацікавлені в лідерстві українців в галузі авіаперевезень.
Фактично"Антонов"постійно перебував у стані"прихованого економічного розлучення"
з Росією ще задовго до анексії Криму і реальної війни на Донбасі.
І був вимушений ще тоді починати думати про відмову від усього російського.
"Антонов"це відчував вжез середини 2012-го,
коли російські постачальники вже дуже холодно ставилися до"Антонова".
Тому те, що можна було зробитиin house -в Україні або в самому "Антонові" - воно, вже замінено.
Наразі"Антонов"наближається до того, щоб майже половину всього, що є в літаку,
можна було виробити або в Україні, або за кордоном, зокрема в країнах НАТО.
Символічно, що і локатори в"Руслані"вже більше і нерадянські, і неросійські.
Якщо ви подивитися на фото"Руслана"2011-2012 років і раніше, то побачите,
що тут під обтікачем була така невелика виїмка,як подвійне підборіддя. Наразі цього немає.
Бо встановили американський локатор,
який використовується у великої кількості на літаках вусьому світі.
Таких от подвійних підборідь в"Руслані"було і є чимало.
Заміна старих технологій і обладнання на сучаснізменшує вагулітака,
посилюючи його конкурентоспроможність.
Пілот "Руслана" з багаторічним стажем і з особистим рекордом у 14 діб польоту
ВікторГончаров вміє керувати"Русланом",  "Мрією"та"Антеєм".
Він бачив усі трансформації літаків, як крок за кроком змінюється його робоче місце.
Щоб вночі читати. Є кілька режимів інтенсивності.
Літак,каже пілот, знаходиться в постійній модернізації.
І все,що тут з’являється - вже давно неросійське.
Ця панельна дошка, системи навігації,хоча і мають радянський"look",
але всередині вже давно-західнідеталі.
Що б ми хотіли змінити? Звичайно, всі ці пульти зникнуть.
Тут вже всі мізки цифрові, хоча індикація ще аналогова. Звичайно, це все піде.
Якщо ви можете уявити рідкокристалічний монітор,
це приблизно ось такого розміру кілька приладів уздовж дошки.
Тут теж буде геть інша панель. Теж рідкокристалічна.
Глибока модернізація літака почнеться в червні цього року.
На це підприємство витратить кілька десятків мільйонів доларів.
Ставати дійсно незалежним від радянського минулого і російського впливу,
кажуть співробітники підприємства, стає все більш цікавим.
Звичайно, крісло вже можна і заміняти - оббити його шкірою м’якою.
Контракт з російськоюавіакомпанією"Волга-Дніпро"
"Антонов"розірвав з початком російської агресії проти України.
І з того часу, каже пілот Гончаров, його все менше бачать вдома.
Мені сказали, що діти не твої, вони виросли без тебе.
У всіх, хто має відношення до"Русланів",
з часів відмови від російських комплектуючих роботи побільшало.
Інженери вже зайняті планами з модернізації на найближчі 5-10 років.
Адже треба вже зараз встановлювати обладнання,
яке буде завтра відповідати вимогам авіаперевезень.
З ким співпрацювати-керівництво обирає шлях максимальної незалежності від будь-якої держави.
В ідеалі усе робити в Україні.
Принаймні, за серце "Руслана" - задвигун-тут вже давно спокійні.
Адже його розробили і виробили у Запоріжжі.